i was turned on to this by edmund smirk  one of my favorite pseudonymous twitter  accounts  there was a clip of catherine mckinnon a  radical feminist from 1993 and she's  arguing with conservatives and she's  saying you guys are too weak on porn and  she says you know if you were sitting in  a room and you heard a lady get knocked  around the walls in the other room you  would run out your door you'd knock down  you might call the police but because  you're seeing it on a screen or you're  reading it in a newspaper or not a  newspaper in a magazine it's you think  it's totally fine and it's this  separation because it seems disembodied  because we're living in this virtual  right the virtual world but your virtual  the things you do in the virtual world  have moral qualities as well